[Music]
my talk now is about one specific event
of gravitational waves arising from two
black holes that were colliding about
1.3 billion years ago
black holes are regions of space and
time with ever increasing curvature
their vacuum so I'm not putting any
spheres in this movie here and you see
that the presence of the black hole in
the curvature of this plane that is
rotating around as the two black holes
are rotating around this is a computer
calculation performed here in Canada one
of the ones that Lewis was referring to
that tells us what happens when black
holes collide and that also tells us
that a characteristic gravitational wave
shape they are emitting when they are
colliding now the movie is slowing down
because the codes I have approached each
other and about to collide which is
where the warpage of space and time is
most extreme afterwards you have one
larger black hole formed space is
settling down again into a question
state and the gravitational waves are
propagating out into the universe into
all directions away from me from the
merger of these two black holes 1.3
billion years later this particular
cavitational wave has hit earth about
two years ago and as Lewis pointed out
when a clever national wave propagates
through earth it stretches and squeezes
earth and any type of matter and space
and time itself in a very characteristic
pattern to get a sense of how minut
these distortions actually are this
movie was exaggerated how minutely see
this distortions actually are I need to
resort remind you of a few small small
things starting with a human hair which
has a diameter of about 0.1 millimeters
or is about a million atoms a course and
an atom itself has a very tiny nucleus
in this in the middle that is only about
100,000 times the size of an atom so
gravitational waves hit earth that the
strongest ones they are they deform the
earth by roughly the size of a nucleus
the instruments with which we are trying
to detect gravitational waves are
smaller than the earth so the
deformations within the instruments are
smaller still we are talking about at a
change in length of about one in a
thousand times the size of an atomic
nucleus or one in a hundred millionth of
the size of an atom it's utterly
astoundingly small effects we need to
measure in order to detect those
amazingly large and violent explosions
okay people actually have half done this
the LIGO instruments two years ago have
detected the very first gravitational
wave and two more since then
Laika consists of two identical
observatories one in washington state
called in a place called Hanford and one
in Livingston Louisiana each one of
these observatories has a big central
station with laser systems in it and it
then bounces laser beams along these
four kilometer long arms in two
different electrons what happens is
indicated here so the laser light is
pointing around the two arms and the
whole system is set up in such a way
that when a gravitational wave comes by
you get a tiny amount of light out here
at the output port the physical
principle behind has to do with the wave
nature of light that you have the waves
of the light going up along the arms and
the arms arranged precisely such that at
the output port there is destructive
interference and no light is coming out
here except when a gravitational wave
actually wriggles the mirrors and and
this offsets this this delicate balance
of arrangement here and then there's a
little bit of light coming out of the
dark port that's the fundamental idea
and how like was detecting gravitational
waves there's a vast amount of extra
difficulties and challenges and
my point in this experiment and here I'm
showing a few images of the LIGO
instrument in in Livingston this is the
Central Station with the beam splitter
these vacuum results are about four or
five meters high and here is the the one
arm and the other arm going off for four
kilometers in to four kilometers
distance like Oh actually are the
biggest vacuum systems in the world the
biggest hole in the Earth's atmosphere
here's one of the stations with the
delicate mirror assembly built to
isolate from any external perturbations
and at the bottom of this assembly hang
the actual like of mirrors about 40
centimeters across
among the most perfectly polished
surfaces that we've ever done this
instrument is very complicated and so
the collaboration that has developed it
as building it and operating it has
about a thousand people involved
scattered about 60 or 70 institutions
and essentially all continents Canada is
represented here in Toronto through the
Canadian Institute for Theoretical
astrophysics okay so what have we seen
almost two years ago the first
gravitational wave was measured and it
was announced with big fanfare about one
and a half years ago in February last
year the Hanford instrument measured
this particular shape of the
gravitational wave increasing amplitude
increasing frequency until eventually
everything settles down to zero again
and here's this remarkably small scale
of ten to the minus twenty one that that
Lewis was already alluding to Livingston
has seen a very similar looking shape
shown in blue here again increasing
amplitude increasing frequency until it
finally settles down to zero again and
then the most important feature here is
if you take the hand for the observation
and put it on top of the Livingston one
you see that the two signals agree with
each other so two instruments four
thousand kilometer separated from each
other have recorded the same astonishing
minut signal
arising from the curvature of space and
time and it's the fact that we are
seeing twice the same thing widely
separated that makes us so confident
that this really is a gravitational wave
from the depths of the universe and not
just a bird flying above or somebody
closing the car to a 500 miles away to
give you some sense of scale black holes
the black hole that the two black holes
I'm talking about are about ten million
and twelve million times the mass of the
Earth and size-wise the the event
horizon the region of these black holes
where you cannot escape into the outside
again it's a few hundred kilometers
across the black holes are separated by
about five hundred kilometers and they
are orbiting about each other ten times
per second at a speed about a sixth of
the speed of light imagine going from
Detroit to Ottawa ten times a second and
back it's it's totally astonishing the
amount of energy emitted in the
cavitational waves by this one collision
of the two black holes during the 0.1
seconds where they ever most violent was
about 50 times as much as the entire
rest of the universe combined so those
are totally astonishingly large
explosions unfortunately those black
holes are in a vacuum environment there
is no gas nearby so all this energy goes
entirely into cavitational waves and the
only way to ever see these particular
types of colliding black holes is
through the gravitational wave detectors
now we can do cool things with this
types of observation of course
discovering gravitational waves is the
first thing we were quite proud of but
now the the more important part is the
future to use gravitational waves to
explore science and the universe lewis
already alluded to the question was
einstein white our black holes really
black holes too they really behave as
predicted by the theory that Einstein
wrote on more than a hundred years ago
well we have here in play the
measurement of the instruments and this
time in colors on top of them I've
overlaid the
of the computer calculation I showed you
in my first slide the prediction of
Einstein's equations and as you can see
the measurement and the computer
calculation of Einstein's equations they
are in nearly perfect agreement so this
particular gravitational wave is
perfectly consistent with the prediction
of Einstein's equations as are we don't
need any additional physics right now we
don't need to modify Einstein's
equations we can also use so yet another
time as so many times before the answer
is yes to the question was Einstein
white we can also use gravitational
waves to explore the universe to learn
new things about the universe that were
known beforehand in this particular case
the presence of black holes with about
30 and 35 solar masses merging into a
black hole was about 62 solar masses we
believe this process were to happen that
black holes collide and form bigger ones
but there was no evidence beforehand no
we have it and this particular size of
black holes or 30 solar masses was
entirely unknown beforehand black holes
before were only known as nice puny ones
between 5 and 15 solar masses and the
very massive ones that Lewis mentioned a
million solar masses to a billion solar
masses and by the way this is not the
only binary black hole collision in the
universe
LIGO has detected two more indicated
here as well in this graph and if you
add up the numbers within the entire
universe there's about a one-play cold
collision every 15 minutes so during my
talk quite likely a gravitational wave
from colliding black holes has passed
through this room or wedding
unfortunately almost certainly this
particular one that happened this today
or this last 15 minutes was from too far
away that the likeö instruments wouldn't
be able to see them because the waves
are too weak when they arrive here on
earth and besides actually precisely
this week the likeo instrument is down
anyway so
no gravitational waves this week like
was not the only gravitational wave
observatory that's that's in existence
more of them are being commissioned in
Europe in India and in Japan and was the
biggest set of instruments we will be
seeing more events and we will learn
more information about each event most
importantly it will be able to pinpoint
much more accurately out of which
direction in the sky a certain
gravitational wave is coming so where
then we can point normal electromagnetic
telescopes and look in the same region
in this kind to close I'd like to show
you another movie one of my favorite
movies so this is currently just an
image of the Milky Way where I'm
highlighting three stars so you can see
them in the next slide as well and now
I'm going to place my favorite binary
black hole between us the camera and the
Milky Way in the background as Lewis has
already pointed out matter in especially
black holes distort the space around
them and distort the direction light is
traveling in so my stars have suddenly
moved to a different place here a
further away and the black holes are
sitting here in the middle if you look
carefully you actually see that there's
multiple ways the light can go around
the black holes and reaches so here's a
second copy of these three stars and
there's actually a third copy here in
the middle now let's turn off these
these circles again and actually make
the black hole's move and now all this
this lensing of light around the black
holes becomes time dependent and leads
to this really really beautiful movie
which actually is completely correct and
in terms of how colliding black holes
would look like if you were sufficiently
close to them and if you were to slow
down your time by about a factor of a
hundred and with that I would like to
close and only point out further that
LIGO also has a lot of outreach material
on their website so thank you very much
[Applause]